et
puisant à les sources qui semblait être
taries isaac mizrahi à retrouver l'art
de sertir par milliers des petits blocs
de pierre répartis selon des rites et
provoque lens où la lumière des
compositions multiples
avec lui rooney la mosaïque sa technique
celle de l'époque romaine implantation à
la main dans un mortier frais de
minéraux divers marbre du roussillon
d'italie granit travertin pâte de verre
l'enduit composaient le show vive et un
sablé ciment et déposer directement sur
les murs
la mosaïque est exécuté par petites
surfaces sans raccord à par an à partir
de la maquette a grandi à l'échelle
réelle
ces numéros sont taillés par lui et
selon les nécessités à partir de plaques
de différentes épaisseurs occupe de
volume varie
est-ce que vous souvenez de la première
fois où vous avez vu une mosaïque
oui c'était l'impression magnifique et
gêné souvenait encore le plus à l'époque
où j'ai commencé à m'intéresser à
travailler dans les ateliers de mosaïque
rouge à paris et c'était en 46 j'avais
appelé 11 12 ans j'ai créé 12 ou 13 ans
et c'était en israël on a fait un plan
bien d'après à pied dont le sud du
valais de de lac de tibériade dans les
vallée du jourdain et nous sommes
arrivés à un endroit c'était pas loin du
de la ville de bébés tiens c'était une
vie les philistins et à l'époque c'était
ils ont trouvé une mosaïque dans une
ancienne synagogue dont nous sommes au
sol et qui représentait les 12 signes du
zodiaque devenu peintre puis mosaïste
misrahi pratique alternativement les
deux expressions si ces peintures comme
ses mosaïques ont la même source
d'inspiration ou lyrisme et dynamisme
s'allient pour créer toute une
mythologie sensuelle et charnelle
c'est dans la musique que son univers
confine au fabuleux la différence
il est en profondeur je veux dire en
profondeur dans la mosaïque ce qui
concerne la technique et en a placé la
peinture il y a une autre participation
avec la matière
ceux d en sensations tout à fait
différente
et quelle est celle que vous préférez
je préfère d'envié mais il y a une
préférence dans la peinture ge dans mes
dessins qui sont très importants et qui
met dans d'autres satisfactions que je
ne trouve pas dans la mosaïque
mais pour moi comme une rose à x est un
aboutissement de quelque chose mon
immense talent dans l'espace et
ce que je veux faire ma façon de
s'exprimer de quoi
c'est une construction architecturale
par exemple maintenant là tous ces
problèmes que j'ai de les resserrer où l
argile et surface sa demande de ces
pages de dessins industriels
mais il ya quand même une construction
de la matière de la matière que j'espère
le faire parler dans le résultat des
choses quand on est devant une peinture
il ya déjà une définit une le frontier
le quart et le cad et la visio elle se
elle se braque la l'intérieur les limité
de l'illimité et on est plus loin avec
avec notre intérieur et on essaie de
d'approfondir cet espace là
il semble que misrahi en domestiquant
lapierre en la faisant éclater sous la
lumière parvient à accorder l'eau et le
végétal est à l'image des grands fonds
marins a provoqué l'imagination mais une
imagination nez de l'inconscient
contre la peinture et la mosaïque
monumentale l'art mural
c'est comme un cheval qui voudraient
kiki en train de foncer et qu'on le
tient avec les rederien c'est la
peinture il est là il va vers quelqu'un
quelque part mais on le retient
tandis qu'avec l'art mural on le laisse
les rênes et viva viva web
il peut monter il de sang et il peut
aller vers la droite
j'ai démontré que je travaillais par
exemple des compositions de 10 ou de 15
mètres de long moi je vois pas pourquoi
ça doit s'arrêter à 15 mètres ça peut
aller à 15 km ou encore il n'y a pas de
limite ça continue c'est un tweet
mais ce qui est très particulier chez
vous c'est cette utilisation du
mouvement cette recréation du mouvement
un mouvement qui suggère vous arrivez à
partir d'abstraction par ce mouvement
agréé à l'imaginaire des formes
je crois ça m'intéresse pas elle c'est
pas mon but de cour piller la nature de
faire des reproductions et la nature
elles existent hélas été créé c'est
quelque chose de merveilleux
c'est quelque chose qui est supérieur à
notre imagination et à nous mêmes et on
peut apprendre c'est quelque chose qui
nous donne qui nous
ce comme le gosse elle est un temps doux
tout est imprimé dans son cerveau il y a
quelque chose qu'on peut tirer de la
nature et après comme on dit dans le
langage pictural en développe son propre
langage sa propre personnalité mais
c'est une question des années et des
années de travail
ça vient pas du jour au lendemain
né sur le pourtour de la méditerranée la
mosaïque fleuron de la décoration
antique médiévale devient avec misrahi
éléments d'architecturé avec lui les
fresques de pierre serti s'élève
participant ainsi à la composition
générale
ce que je veux donner c'est pas de
abstrait c'est des formes qui sont pas
figurative
quand vous dites mais je fais pas ça
veut dire je laisse le spectateur les
gens je leur donne laisse la liberté de
s'imaginer aussi de même 2,2 d'essayer
de voir même de choses que moi j'ai pas
prévu pas faire plus mais je me suis pas
fait se rendit compte qu'ils existent il
ya beaucoup de choses qu'on le fait
inconsciemment il faut pas faire les
choses uniquement avec des calculs de
savon ça veut dire voilà cette ligne il
faut qu'elle aille comme ça et l'autre à
travers etc
il faut laisser un peu la spontanéité
qu'il existe et qu'elle est très
importante et même l'inconscience qui le
déjeuner faux pas est coupée et
repousser les choses vers l'est à
l'endroit où ils ne sortiront jamais il
faut les laisser gg ir et ça c'est
beaucoup plus important
oui en fait vous proposer plus que vous
n'imposer oui je propose beaucoup plus
que d'imposer c'est un peu de violer les
gens et les gens ils ont leur sans
hésiter ils ont leurs désirs ils ont
leurs
l'univers il faut essayer de leur ouvrir
la porte de quelque chose qu'il puisse
entrer et se sentir bien
mes premières recherches et travaux dans
les panneaux des mosaïques que j'ai
commencé à faire là l'école de vous à
l'abri
c'était des sujets bibliques
je choisis les sujets bibliques parce
que j'étais touché par ce sujet l'un et
en plus à l'époque que j'avais besoin
d'une impulsion d'une raison extérieure
ou me faire démarrer et pousser les
mémés raisons intérieures qu'aujourd'hui
ça s'est renversé un peu c'est le monde
à l'envers
je veux dire par là que j'ai pas besoin
des raisons extérieures et encore
maintenant j'ai vu que certaines de vos
toiles l'une s'appelle et c'est une
peinture la reine de saba
il y as derrière nous
mosaïques fresques très grande et très
belle qui s'appelle les quatre prophète
les quatre les quatre évangélistes bombe
a eu tout ça me paraît pas absolument
évident sur le plan de la représentation
oui oui c'était des raisons d
inspiration
c'était symbolique comme je l'avais
expliqué c'était des raisons pour me
pousser à créer quelque chose
maintenant il peut avoir les quatre
évangélistes dans une mosaïque i qui ne
s'appelle pas quatre évangélistes et
qu'on ne voit pas exactement le taureau
legs le lion et l'ange et qui peut avoir
quelque chose d'un message ou moi je
cherche pas à faire des messages mais
c'est dans l'ambiance qui est créé par
par ses formes maintenant j'aurais pu
j'aurais pu prendre un autre chemin
mais si je choisis ce que ces chemins où
je suis aujourd'hui c'est que c'était
toujours pour être conforme pour
s'adapter à mon caractère dans mon
tempérament et sans me forcer moi même
de faire des choses il fallait faire le
vrai mot ce que je ressors avec comme je
le fais avec les avec les autres tout à
l'heure vous avez dit une chose qui me
touche
moi personnellement beaucoup c'est que
lorsque vous vous réfléchissez à la
peinture ou à la mosaïque votre
préférence presque vers la mosaïque
parce que elle à une projection sur le
public qui est beaucoup plus plus total
beaucoup plus globale que ne l'est la
peinture qu'il s'adresse en fait au
monsieur qui a eu la chance de pouvoir
acheter le tableau alors que vos
sculptures elles s'adressent à tout un
village où un tout une école où toute
une collectivité
oui c'est exact avec la mosaïque
ça va beaucoup plus vers le plus grand
public depuis ce procès pour ça ça
m'intéresse beaucoup plus de travailler
par exemple avec une municipalité avec
des mairies des villes
pour faire quelque chose dans
l'environnement les gens y ce plan
tellement qu'ils ont rien autour que ce
triste que sais je sais tout ça alors
et je crois qu'il faut grimper selon
deux grands et d'aidé pour ne rendre un
peu l'environnement plus heureuse et
plus
satisfaisante si on peut dire ça comme
ça et ça fait appel bien sûr beaucoup
plus de jambes qui on profite et qu'il
voit cette décoration
là où elle se trouve et qui ont ça
serait parti de l'environnement et de la
vie de tous les jours
en